shocking body camera footage shows
football player Odell Beckham Jr
insulting a passenger as the wide
receiver gets kicked off his flight for
belligerent Behavior
it happened on November 27th at the
Miami International Airport obj was on a
plane headed to Los Angeles when flight
attendants raised concern before takeoff
he needs to get off right they're very
intoxicated belligerent no he just that
he was unresponsive for octopus
wouldn't pushed to try to get to put the
seat belt on but it was still possible
flight staff told Miami-Dade Police
Officers obj was unresponsive and later
refused to put on his seat belt when
they asked him to get off the plane and
catch another one leaving shortly after
he refused but now he's
foreign
body camera footage shows officers make
contact with obj and initially deem him
okay before a flight attendant asks
about his pants
yeah
yeah they're on are they on now yeah
they weren't on before
no after that flight staff order all the
passengers except obj off the flight as
they're deplaning conversation gets
heated
I would never
ever ever in my life
get off the plane for you
specifically you body camera footage
captures obj insulting a passenger as
officers physically pull him back you
gonna wait 40 minutes
enjoy the cheese board on the way home
obj continues to express his irritation
with flight staff saying quote all you
had to do was wake me up
you ain't nothing to me bro
got like fucked up I'm sorry
all you have to do is wake me up and
then go that way minutes later obj can
be heard asking officers to avoid the
man he got into an argument with when
escorting him off the plane
don't worry about it as obj begins to
exit the plane dozens of people begin
booing and yelling at the football
player
[Music]
on Thursday the famed wide receiver
addressed the incident in a threat of
tweets reading in part quote no matter
how much I've grown is still the hardest
thing for me to do is let someone play
with my name period for those that know
me know me you know exactly how I am in
a separate tweet he made reference to
the comment he said to the passenger
back in November saying quote have a
blessed day and enjoy the cheese board
with a cheese Emoji reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie